well Superman's come out what do we have
to look forward to now ha sorry there's
only one hobbits the hobbits singular
one hobbits some wizards a lot of
dwarves a lot of elves and a dragon yeah
that that's um looking forward to so the
first trailer to the hobbit the
desolation of smaug has come out or
Smaug I guess is pronounced snout like
Gandalf will say schmuck is a dragon I
guess I should start saying it like that
for accuracy's sake I'm gonna say Smaug
and smell good to mix it up how can you
say this trailer gets you jacked for it
man does your journey good you seek that
which would bestow upon you the right to
rule the trailer starts out on the
adventure aspect you know there in a
boat they're climbing a huge statue got
that middle-earth type feel going on it
looks like we're gonna see more conflict
with the dwarves and the elves that one
scene where Thorin Oakenshield in front
of that one jet head elf dude the quest
to reclaim a homeland and slay a dragon
first of all Thorin looks like a badass
right there I'm just gonna I'm gonna
throw that out there into the universe
cuz Thorin always looks like a badass
but right there he particularly looks
like a badass I think I'm gonna get a
Thorin Oakenshield tattoo I'm gonna get
his face tattooed on my face and I'll
just look like a badass
I'll even keep the cobwebs and dust from
that shot I'll get that right here no
you can tell he's looking at this dude
he's like I remember you man you're the
elf who backed his army down when we
needed your help at Erebor and we lost
the city to the dragon because of you
even if they wouldn't have helped that's
how he sees the situation he's like yeah
you're the reason I don't like elves
you're the reason I'm kind of a broken
bitter [ __ ] in general however that
makes me an interesting character so the
audience they thank you the rest of
middle-earth however particularly the
dwarves we think you're a chode
do not think I won't kill him flag
glasses here he's rocking his bow and
arrow Evangeline Lilly comes in to
playing she plays an elf we all knew she
would play an elf because she's a really
slender attractive chick in middle-earth
odds are she's gonna be an elf we see
some more cool action too it looks like
it has it's fun sprightly adventure
vibes
I was looking at this trailer and I was
like I think that's it right there this
what separates the Hobbit from The Lord
of the Rings trilogy everything is more
crisp and brighter and smoother I guess
that's because of the bump and
technology in a decade's time but I
suppose that's why I prefer personally
the grit of the Lord of the Rings
trilogy but I still have me some Hobbit
fun
did anyone else get confused when they
sell that one dude in this trailer she
waking that beast
were you like Orlando Bloom do you play
to different people he's actually not
Orlando Bloom but I have called that guy
the other Orlando Bloom and other
reviews that I've done in movies that
he's been in but it's a nice fun bit of
irony that they're in a movie together
and now the jokes can keep flowing that
is totally Orlando Bloom but not but it
is but it's not the bummer is there's no
Gollum to look forward to in this one in
The Hobbit an unexpected journey you
know the trailers played up Gollum we
all wanted to see Gollum the riddles in
the dark segment that was such a cool
part of the movie in this movie there's
not gonna be a Gollum however there is
something to look forward to in the form
of something that flies and breathes
fire in his voice by Cumberbatch yeah
there is that dragon thing I love the
way this trailer ends the way it leads
right into the title I bet that gave me
goosebumps that my left was your dragon
how can you not love that just honestly
the hair on the back of my neck was like
whoa dragon time he didn't even have to
say that was a dragon you might as well
have just said what it actually is that
was the point the point of all of it
it's here we are and then you're like
cool alright yeah the trailers wrapped
up no not exactly we still need to see a
hobbit [ __ ] himself
and that's what happened right there a
hobbit [ __ ] himself I know that because
I would have [ __ ] myself series really
put yourself in his position right there
he's like oh my I I do believe I've shat
myself as what happens when the glowing
eyeball on the dragon is looking right
at you the very menacing situation he's
in right there I have such a DD man I'm
telling you guys I am all over the place
as I'm like Superman this is the end
that's right Superman and star trek into
darkness was good this trailer was just
like nope the hobbit the desolation of
smaug there it is
watch it remember it loved it and I do
all those things
so the hobbit the desolation of smaug
have you seen the trailer what do you
think of it whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]
Oh